I'm here today to talk to you about
progressive web apps and I filled in for
another speaker that dropped out
originally I was only meant to be here
to interview Imogene tonight about what
she's doing and it's kind of pale in
comparison what I'm doing but I think
it's a very important topic and I work
in a team that talks a lot of our
progressive web apps and I want to talk
to you today about demystifying it a bit
and making it a bit more understanding
for you what progressive Web Apps mean
and what they mean for you and what you
can do with them rather than like oh god
it's the new cool thing and if you don't
know if you don't understand it then
you're already out of a job and homeless
tomorrow and these kind of things so
ever get super excited about pwace but
there's it's a heart to find a
understanding what's going on there so
there is a lot of like hyped going on
about it so I'm Chris Harmon I work for
a small start-up named incidentally of
Seattle that's been around for 40 years
and what's the bane of my existence as a
web developer when the last 20 years
until I joined them and we finally got
rid of Internet Explorer as the main
browser and I connected collected all
the things that are here if you want to
have them later on to click through and
to play with at the AKMs slash mobile
you're out because I gave that talk at
the mobile era conference before as well
because in two days I couldn't write a
new talk cause I gotta give another talk
on Monday Tuesday Thursday and next
Wednesday so I'm kind of full up already
if you want to follow me on Twitter it's
code port it's the easiest way to reach
me as well I tweet a lot about
technology about artificial intelligence
a lot about the web as it is right now
and pictures of my dog and kittens and
hedgehogs so if that's missing in your
life as well that's another good source
for that so progressive web apps are all
the rage everybody's talking about that
Google IO has an OD chrome dev summit
has just been and everything was PWA
their Microsoft we've been talking about
pwace before Samsung is all over it
Mozilla is all over it right now
Apple is interested
so we are thinking about what's going on
there and every time we have a hype it's
very confusing because the oldest
messaging is like our net our framework
gives you pwace for free and you can
build pwace without knowing what they
are yes you can but that also means
you're building things that nobody needs
and nobody wants you just called it
something cool to be part of a hype when
pwace became a thing about one and a
half years two years ago alex russell
and frances Berryman defined them in a
blog post about all these things to the
PWA has to be it has to be progressive
it has to be responsive Network
independent app like fresh safe
discoverable reengaged able installable
and linkable all these things are great
things to have an application and all
these things make absolute sense but
they're pretty much overloading anybody
who just wants to learn what the hell of
PWA is because if you tell people you've
got have finished 11 things before it's
there they're like well write up and
build an Android app because that's
easier it's too much to ask for in most
cases because we're busy developers and
we're not necessarily um owning our time
frames as well so all times we want to
do the right thing but we have to ship
it first and then later on we can fix it
which is the biggest lie we tell to
every developer ever on this planet
because you never get the time to fix it
it just stays there and is embarrassing
on your on your CV for the rest of your
life so we got to do something about
that the biggest problem that a lot of
people have when it comes to pwace is
the a part where it's like it has to be
an application you're like well I don't
build applications I just run the
biggest newspaper website of Norway or
something like that I don't want to have
an application
why does these functionalities wise to
produce new hype only about apps and it
doesn't have to be not all things that
the pw8 technology is applicable to have
to be applications your blog your ebook
your artistic photography thingy all of
these things can benefit from the
technology stack that makes up a PWA
and that's totally ok you don't have to
turn everything into an app personally I
don't think
you crisp the Christian hilemon app is
something you would install because it's
kind of creepy to have me as an app when
there's only space for 20 apps on your
phone I'm not that important I'm not
that interesting there's a great article
by my colleague Aaron Gustafson about
this that explains all the benefits that
all the different features that you
might have on the web as content can can
have in the PWA stack I think it's more
important when I'm talking to clients
right now a lot and I'm talking about to
enterprise people I'm talking a lot to
to people from from the retail
environment they all have an idea what
progressive web apps are so it's easier
to tell them what they're not to begin
with so to basically stop these same
stupid questions all the time I just did
a video series which is gonna come out
soon and my favorite was when when I
mean I'd talk to people saying okay
pwace or HTML CSS and JavaScript content
that gets new technologies and added to
it to become something that's apt like
and gets the benefits of an app they're
like great so I can use my c-sharp app
and turn it into a PWA you're like no
you don't go from binary to HTML that
doesn't work you do it the other way
around so how do how do develop first
and only know C shop do it and I'm like
they do it differently they do it it's
it's very hard to explain to people that
it's not an app model as you consider it
so the first thing it's not a tick box
in your development flow there's not
gonna be a magical thing that says like
now make this a PW a done let's go to
the pub it's not the end of all native
development it's totally fine to ride a
thick client application it's totally
fine to only have an iOS app it's
totally fine to only have an Android app
it's it's daring to have a Windows or
Windows Mobile only app but there are
other things where you can publish and
if you only want to publish on that
platform you're not a terrible person
it's ok you don't have to do everything
on the web it makes more sense to do
everything on the web but that's a
different story it's what every it's not
what every web content needs to get
converted into not everything has to
become a PWA if you've got a static
website that hadn't changed in the last
40 years fine it's probably gonna be
cached for 10,000
already it's good you don't need to
upgrade it you don't need to do
something else with it it's not native
apps Potter to the web we've done that
and failed every single time when we
said like okay my newest HTML technology
and put it on the web and then people
just do these huge things and put them
on the web were wondering why people
didn't like them they were really slow
they were really hard to use and we were
just like blaming web technology not
being ready rather than building
something that makes sense on the web
and then enhancing it in environments
where it becomes more applicable like an
operating system or a mobile system to
me they are a development approach of
using a set of technologies that allows
web content to be app like experiences
including offline functionality
notifications and device access that is
what a PWA to me is so in essence it's
an HTML based JavaScript CSS based web
thing that according to what where you
run it gets better
so you have it on a mobile device that
has a lot of space to store it it
becomes an offline application you have
an you have an opportunity to give
notifications it because it gets
notifications it can update in the
background out of a sudden it upgrades
in the background so next time I come to
it I don't get asked to download the
whole thing again and this is what it's
about we're breaking the idea of an
application being something that is a
huge monolithic thing that end users
have to get install not like and delete
instead we have something that you
follow a link you play with it you like
it and then next time you come there by
the way I'm available offline now by the
way do you want to give me access to
your camera by the way do you want me I
want me to allow to store more data on
your device and the UX of that is the
thing that we have to really nail this
time because every single time we said
oh this is an HTML application you just
have to get it from that store and
actually buy that kind of hardware to
use it people didn't want it they are
progressive does that means the
experience of the application improves
with the capability of the device and
the quality of the connection
you cannot tell a user to buy another
device unless you're actually selling
that device and it's only for that
device but if you want users you have to
let them use what they already have
they're used to it
they know how to use it they're happy
with it they would love your content on
it but there's nothing more frustrating
to me when I go to a website that
already uses like 12 megabyte of
unpatched react core whatever JavaScript
library thing that makes my fan run and
then the first thing I get is like do
you want to download our app like you
just wasted 12 megabyte of your off your
data is the data storage on your device
for this month on reading this you want
to download another 50 that you don't
have anymore this is just insulting to
our end users because we want to have
more control of our end users we
shouldn't be making them download more
things we should make them give the
first thing first and get better when
they come back or get better when the
device can do it when javascript is not
available like a bad wireless for
example or something went wrong in the
building of your thing it still should
work i can go to google calm being calm
and i have a search box and i press a
button and i get a search result the
reason is that both of these companies
make money by showing you search results
and ads around it this is how the whole
model works so the one use case of
search things find things will always
work when javascript is available when
my machine has a fast connection when my
machine has storage out of a sudden I
get the image previews I get an
autocomplete I get the all the cool
things that made search much more
interesting than it is but the main use
case is always what works and we gave up
on that a long time ago we've forgotten
that we want to have one use case for
our end users instead we give them the
kitchen sink and everything else we had
then we had lying around and hope that
they pick the things that they love and
that's why all the things we use
nowadays are so bloated that we don't
even want to use them any longer
progressive web apps are an opportunity
to take these technologies and clean up
and speed up what we currently have the
web has become an image of ourselves
lazy obese and an and slow and this is
not what the web
supposed to be once you like me and
you're traveling all the time and you
get like really flaky connections you
get super annoyed when you cannot send
off a form until some JavaScript has
loaded it does something completely
random the amount of times I have to
extra turn on developer tools and and
enable us a bit button to press it in
the developer tools because somebody
thought they have to download 50 mag in
the background is really really
frustrating to me and this is not a
cheap device this is not a cheap device
I have money I would love to use your
stuff just don't put anything in my way
that stops me from doing that it's an
opportunity to reconsider what we call
apps and how users find use and discard
them and that's what we're doing right
now doesn't work if you look at the
statistics of any of the app stores iOS
Android Windows Store people are not
happy they are using them because they
have to but most of the apps that people
download there lose all their users in
the first three months 66% of the apps
in the indie Google App Store have never
been downloaded
not even once but if somebody paid a lot
of money for saying like you gotta have
an app a website is what they had a 1997
apps is what people want right now
trying to find things in stores as a
pain my brother is a budding comic book
artist and I thought I'd do him a good
thing and buy him an Android tablet and
then I was like hey cool painting app
for Android avid apps never look for
painting app in the App Store because
you get like paint this dog paint this
elephant paint this kitten paint this
Mickey Mouse somebody just created 6,000
apps with like one JPEG and the painting
thing on top of that I could do in ten
lines of JavaScript the only thing I
found Autodesk
nobody would expected me to find a
company that I thought was outdated in
1985 to be the only one that writes
something great for Android for comic
book artists to use because there's an
overload there you go to see you tell
somebody like hey I've got this app go
to the App Store the app store says like
well you got to be logged in cool I
login you need to have a credit card oh
that's a lot of people already don't
have a credit card don't have access to
one cannot actually download and access
the thing then
like give me a pint of blood give me
your firstborn show me why you come in
like these all these questions you can
see that from like a hundred users that
you try to route to reach seven comes
through after all these steps so we got
a take off these barriers and let people
consume our things and then buy them
it's a much better way of getting there
so for the purpose of this keynote live
you know to talk this time let's talk
about apps let's talk about not the web
stuff but only about apps themselves or
in other words as I call them interfaces
to do things with if your app only shows
me your content it's not a flicker it's
not an app an app should be something I
customized to myself I put something in
I get something back I collect something
I do something with that thing it's not
your company's CEO saying they're
welcome to our app nobody needs that
kind of crap but we keep having to build
these kind of things so the web of old
isn't fun that's our travel app that I
have to use in the company that I work
for right now I'm not calling any names
but you all know I get these you know
these flashbacks to 1997 when I had to
make rounded corners for windows for
Internet Explorer 6 7 these kind of
things when I look at that thing every
single drop-down that is too small on
that 3000 by 2000 resolution that I have
right now does a reload while I'm
clicking it so while I'm typing
something in a Trump's or next form and
gives me something I didn't want you
know these T's like Mossadegh SharePoint
1997 kind of interfaces that basically
says I hate you but you have to use it
my favorite about these things is what I
call the Stockholm Syndrome of
interfaces because you go to companies
that use these things for years and you
give them something cooler and they're
like nanananana I planned for 15 years
of 50 minutes of pain every morning of
using that thing I learned that I don't
have to think about it so please don't
give me something that makes me think
I'm happy to use that people stop
defending those because the other ones
are too complex so what was the problem
of the web of old and apps on the web of
old
it first of all the information overload
like I don't want any of that
I need this form
this is all I need and if it's a 2 it
will automatically realize that because
I don't do a one-way here I don't need
all the other information give me
something that I can start with it's UI
for a big screen with roll at low
resolution so this was like when 640
pixels were cool and this is there it
made sense but now in a larger screen
the font is far too small and I'm old I
got glasses it's not fun to use a fat
connection dependency every drop-down
loading something randomly in the
background without telling me that it's
loading something it might just
basically not do anything while I'm
typing in the rest of my content and it
goes away because the page out of a Sun
refreshes and says like I got the new
data that you didn't request
there's no offline experience I cannot
use that thing offline at all I cannot I
mean you cannot look at the data but I
would for example love to see the thing
where I'm supposed to go what my hotel
is and so on and so forth and it's
hardly usable on mobile at all because
it didn't even have the viewport meta
tag so basically you scroll in every
direction and hope you find the form
field that you want to enter in now the
next round of things that we gave we
gave it a cleaner look you know we
didn't use we didn't use Times New Roman
for fonts anymore and these kind of
things and we made it like ooh now it's
flat design it's not like the fake
dropdowns anymore and these kind of
things it's better this is no expense
system that I have to use but options
are still choices there aren't choices
but decisions the more stuff you show me
on the page the more confused I get what
do I want from an expense system I have
an expense can I put that in that's all
I want right now I don't want to see my
expenses from the last 50 month that
should be another option somewhere else
at the end of the process not at the
beginning of it it's a non adaptive UI
so basically on a mobile it wasn't
usable either it's no offline
functionality again and this is for
expenses it's pretty cool I want to take
a picture and put it on my expense
system when I go online it syncs it back
to the server and everybody gets money
and we're all happy no access to useful
hardware options I cannot access the
camera in that thing and there's a
camera in here where I can just put my
expense and take a picture and I'm happy
and I don't have to take it on my phone
put it on Google Drive find it from
Google Drive converted into a PNG from
an from a bitmap to a JPEG and uploaded
on a small connection and
hope my money comes back somehow and
security is by jumping through lots of
Hoops this thing is only possible on our
VPN which hates hotel wireless for
example and basically almost one people
wonder why I don't put my expenses and
I'm like because you hate me because you
make me use this thing this is the app
for it on Windows 10 which is pretty
cool that's exactly what I want
here is what went through your credit
card and it tells me what it is and then
I just put my cat my expense in front of
it take the picture and I'm done and I
can then you do a new expense report or
I can actually sort by date and find my
other expense reports it doesn't show me
everything at the same time it shows me
one thing well show me what I have and
where it should go allow me to quickly
get an overview don't expect an
interaction model don't expect me to use
a keyboard and a mouse I'm using this on
a touchscreen all the time which is much
more fun and a lot of touchscreens are
things nowadays and allow me to use what
my device offers so this way I can take
a picture with the camera that's in my
device rather than having to upload it
somewhere from onedrive Dropbox or
whatever I store Masha
my stuff now the next step of that were
mobile apps they're good but they also
need love they actually are dedicated to
the operating system and to the device a
lot of in a lot of times this is our new
travel app that needed an extra virus
scanner and an extra thing to download
and then it asked me to to set my
Android device to allow for installing
things that are not on the Android store
so basically I went through three
security levels to do a really insecure
thing to my phone before I can use it
not fun either
and there's interesting things this plus
there I would have expected that that
actually means I can order a new flight
or something like that but it just means
that I can type things into that
itinerary which I don't need anymore cuz
all the data is in there so I don't know
what the plus is make the pain of store
access and installation worth my while
if I went through all the paints to out
to download your app and install it and
give it upon a blood of my firstborn and
my credit card then it should be an
excellent excellent experience and work
magically with everything my phone has
to offer let me use the device
it's abilities there's a camera in there
there's a geolocation in there
there's all kind of cool there's a
fingerprint in there like on a mobile
device I'm authentic ated the thing
knows who I am why would I ever need to
type in a password and a username again
after this why does that not go all the
way through and say like well you
installed it we know who you are
we're not gonna give you any other login
any longer we just use that
functionality cuz my passwords people
forget all the time or use the same one
everywhere which password one two three
or something like that let me do what I
came for
I just wanna have my itinerary I want to
book another flight and so on and so
forth use notifications to allow me to
do things don't go let me go don't maybe
open the app all the time just tell me
like by the way your flight is in 30
minutes do you wanna do you want to
check in now yes or no one button
check-in not like okay you want to check
in cool here's a form give me your give
me your your number for your flight
company and your email and so on so
forth no one button should do the thing
this is how clever these machines are
and should work offline and don't expect
massive data downloads on on Wi-Fi
because that's not fun either I was in
Albania the other day and you get these
scary text messages when you're saying
like you're not in the country where you
pay a lot of money for your mobile phone
let me tell you how much it costs right
now and it was I think 12 pound a
megabyte of data which means the average
website which is 2.2 megabyte big
nowadays would cost me the same as a
ticket to see to see Blade Runner and I
hope it's as good because if not I'm
gonna be pissed because I'm not gonna
pay 20 pound for a website that doesn't
do what I'm supposed to do so if we put
these together we have different a
different experience this is a expense
app by a company called Valene and this
this now works here on my mobile device
this is what it looks like it gives me
all these things that I had and it
allows me to scroll through it to find
more information about it I can sort by
those things if I added an expense the
thing has been OCR scanned is in there
as an image and it actually gets the
information out of that if I if I want
to get I get my dates
got an infant and integration into the
keyboard that I was supposed to have my
information has been stored in a device
so there's Auto completion and these
kind of things and I can access the
camera to take pictures and it then gets
the information from that picture rod
and me having to type it in again this
is why it looks on a mobile device and
this is what the same thing looks on a
desktop it's more or less the same
interface but instead of just showing me
the table which would be this wide on
the screen which is when people do wrong
when they when it go mobile first and
then mobile only
it gives me other information next to it
so it gives me a different interface
that is again catered to this kind of
interaction now that I'm on a desktop
machine and the best thing about that
expense manager is not only that it's
open source and on github but it's in
the browser this is a URL as it is a PWA
once I went through that on my Android
device it became an application it had
an icon on the desktop I can click it
and open it full screen without any of
the URL bar and all that [ __ ] about it
but I can use it on a desktop I can use
it on my mobile I can use it on my
tablet it's the same thing and it works
offline where it can and it does it does
it works and it works nice in all the
form factors that you think about so
rather than jumping from one screen to
another to another on a desktop when I
have enough space I don't need to do
that on a mobile device I only get what
I need at that time and not the whole
overload of not knowing what I'm doing
so what are the positives of the web the
link is a simple distribution model the
simplest we have that's the success of
the web as soon as you put something
online somebody will be able to see it
and you will not be able to remove it as
well anymore so that's another thing but
it's a very very amazing thing to do if
I send you a link and say like in a
messenger try this app out cool if I ask
you can you go to the Windows Store and
type that in and make sure you don't do
any any any typos because a lot of
malware is just typos of known
applications as well in these stores
that's a different way of actually
distributing it if you have simple
atomic updates if I want to change the
logo of my PW AF on a website I change
that image if I want to change too
in my android app I rebuilt the app I
resubmitted I asked the user to download
50 Meg's to have a new background image
that's not a good experience because it
was my problem that my logo was not good
flexible layout options we have grids
we've got flag box media queries VW and
we age if you don't know these CSS
things yet look at them they're friggin
amazing and we have a small data
footprint the loading on demand and
environment on my mobile phone
this app is much much smaller than on my
desktop because I don't need all that
content all the time I need just what I
want to have to get the first
interaction in there and then load more
things afterwards don't load them all up
front there's a reusability of code the
conversion to other form factors is easy
I can turn an HTML CSS and JavaScript
into an iOS app into an Android app into
a Windows binary but I can't do it the
other way around because it's not an
open format that care that allows me to
simple conversion the negative of course
is it's patchy access to hardware not
all mobile devices allow me to access
the camera not I cannot access a USB
port in a standardized way yet I cannot
do a reading from a from a card that
needs to be validated these kind of
things are only possible outside the web
right now the verification
authentication can be hard on a mobile
device as I said I'm already
authenticated and the app knows it can
tie into the operating system for doing
that most web technology cannot do that
right now Windows hello is an exception
I can actually get the verification from
the operating system as a JavaScript API
now as well there's a huge fragmentation
of devices and displays you basically do
not know what people use on the web and
don't make any assumptions that they do
it's just not safe especially in a world
where every screen could be any size
right now and resolution and color depth
and so on and so forth and it's patchy
trust in capabilities because we messed
up the web so many times and it's so
easy to to have a data leak on the web
users are not that by trusting it
they're totally happy to have an app
that they don't know what's in there to
install that and trust it but on the web
we always feel like a bit and that's
there's the malware and all kind of
stuff going on
and payments are not easy or expected
the expected thing is something we
really need to fix on a human level we
trained people for a whole generation
that everything on the web is free or
you can use an ad blocker and make it
free this is not healthy this makes no
sense somehow somewhere needs to be paid
and I'd rather pay for applications than
have ads spy on me and actually make
money that way the positives of native
are offline capabilities by design full
access to hardware your authenticated on
a verified device you have a high trust
distribution model people trust things
and more in stores more than they do on
the web and it's easy to pay things at
least in iOS it's easy and Android it
gets better as well unless you're like
me and you have an English credit card
you live in Germany and the German
Travel systems hate you
leading-edge technology normally comes
out of native as well because you have a
competitive advantage once once Apple
said we now have facial recognition
everybody's like oh my god it's amazing
Samsung we had it four years ago
different story but bleeding edge stuff
comes in native and then bleeds into a
standardized web sooner or later but
it's not that fast the negatives of
native huge data footprint with
non-atomic updates you always have to
update all the time like when I get to a
new vial is it says like 60 apps on your
phone want to update I haven't used any
of them in months why do they update why
do they even need updates if I haven't
even used them I think I can should
start to rust and fall apart the more
you don't use them and then vanish
over time there will be amazing slow
update cycles because of negotiation
overhead so I it's fine that I can
update my app and send it to restore but
sometimes it takes days for them to come
back to me and say like okay your app is
updated now and that's really really
dangerous when it comes to security
things high expectations and breakneck
competition like the competition in the
market in stores is huge especially when
it comes to money the price race to the
bottom on Android you cannot sell
anything more than 99 cents because
people are just used to 99 cents you can
then charge them whatever for updates
inside your application but upfront
asking for money is seen as something
dirty
there's bespoke development for each
platform with only minor reuse of course
you've got things like react
and these kind of abstractions but if
you really want to go iOS you probably
go iOS and then you go Android and you
have two different development teams
that don't talk to each other and
actually hate each other so how do pwace
bridge these differences what's the
difference but what's new now what what
have we done better this time well the
first thing a PWA needs to be served
from a secure origin so it needs to be
HTTPS or even better HTTP - once we have
that we can give you a more access to
the device we can allow you to store
more things on the device a plain HTTP
website nowadays is basically and it's
basically a disservice to your end users
with an HTTP bla bla bla example.com I
never know if it's really that man in
the middle attacks are really easy on
that make sure you encrypt your content
because your end-users trust you with
their data once we have that we have a
chance to actually get you a better
functionality get you access to more on
the device with HTTP we just could not
do that without losing lots of
information it's quite sad how many of
the things in html5 we invented I worked
on Firefox OS for Mozilla and we had all
these cool things where like a battery
API and another of a sudden we realized
the battery API API can be used to
fingerprint people if it's over HTTP so
we had to make an HTTP as well so half
the things that we put in there in
2005-2006 had 2015/2016 have to be taken
out right now again or made more secure
or put behind a flag because we find
that the evil people of the web are
actually much faster in embracing new
technology than the people who deliver
things to end-users it's kind of odd and
kind of depressing a bwa needs to have
an app manifest so user agents know
about its requirements and give access
to the needed features and this is for
the first time we have a standardized
manifest this is not make a web OS
manifests and an Apple manifest a
Firefox OS manifest a Windows Mobile
manifest it's a standardized way of
telling it it's a JSON object that you
link from your index.html and this is a
very simple way of looking at its name
short name it got the icons it's gonna
start your LD
has to be a one canonical URL where your
app is running from and it's displaced
and alone this means you don't get any
URLs anymore orientation background
color theme color and then you can add
all the features in there that you need
to have needs access to the payment API
needs access to these and these and
these and these that allows us to have a
better way for end-users to get notified
to give the app access to certain things
when they need it not up front it was
always the big thing in Android as well
to mean older Android so don't know
what's now we're like every app asked
for access to everything like hey here's
a puzzle game with like fluffy animals
can I get access to your address bar no
ok then you can't play the fluffy animal
game because we obviously need that
access what for we don't explain that to
you you want to play fluffy animals okay
I blend give access to it nobody reads
these things like Terms and Conditions
nobody reads the meter there's a
start-up in London and I know that had
me in stitches they are in the middle of
the terms and conditions they had a
sentence saying like if you find this
and read this call this telephone number
we give you five hundred pound it took
them two years for the first person to
find that thing nobody reads terms and
conditions so yeah it's not fun so app
manifests the cool thing is that they're
just another resource on the web they're
adjacent file connected to a domain and
connected to an app so what does that
mean that means for people who go to app
stores to find things they don't even
need to find an extra way you don't even
need to find extra way to submit them
because search engines can index stuff
on the web you know Google there's also
Bing that's another search and you can
go before that if you don't know it yet
they can index and ingest them and this
is what Bing is already doing so if you
we have we had our our our crawlers out
for a year now so if you have an app
manifest on your app on your PWA it's
not many let's put it like this this one
looks like so in the store in the
Windows Store there's an application
called channel 9 which is our video
platform if you do a search for channel
9 Microsoft probably because channel 9
learn the result their search result in
Bing looks like this so you have the app
you have two URL you have
the reviews of the app and you actually
have an install button just by using and
manifest we don't need to do anything
extra for that to get that extra display
functionality in the store itself it it
gets all the data from the manifest as
well so you get the name you get the
description you get the icons you get
the screenshots and you have it listed
in the store so you don't have the
problem that your name listings in the
store differ amazingly from your
application cause once you change
something of that it gets reindex and it
gets shown in the store again the other
big part of the PWA stack are next to
the manifest is a service worker Service
Worker is a JavaScript API only
available over HTTP of course and if you
want to really really quickly describe
it it's like a proxy server that sits in
between the web apps the browser and the
network so it's a in JavaScript
scriptable way to deal with any of the
requests that go from your app to the
server and from the server to your app
which is amazing
cuz in the past we basically hope that
browser's cache things we hope that
something worked now we have full
control over what to store where and
what to do with it so you can use a
serviceworker to define what should be
loaded and cached from where so instead
of having images that you don't want to
reload all the time you just create a
cache called images and put your images
in there and you know next time that
user comes to your website
it comes from their device and they
don't have to download those images
again and if they don't cause traffic on
your server and cause delays because of
the latency of the network you can
intercept network requests and define
what happens you can surf from cache you
can refresh your application in the
background you can convert before this
place or if deep if the end-users device
is capable of web P but all your images
in JPEG you can convert them on the fly
and then store them on their device and
that way you save a lot of traffic for
both of you again as well you can
refresh your app in the background you
can pull new content and notify the user
with push notifications that something
new is available I love that every time
when Twitter's are something new and
people get like oh my god there's
something new I don't even realize it
because I'm using the Twitter PWA all of
a sudden my interface changed not cool
so that's a new feature fine and all the
people oh I read downloaded it this was
so annoying to download and now I
finally am part of this did they have
this new thing with 280 characters I
don't have you seen it yet there's like
this little ring instead of saying how
many characters you got left
I got stuck for half an hour yesterday
because I thought it never finished
loading because it looks like a loading
thing indicator it isn't one super
annoying but fair enough so if you want
to know more about - about PWA and and
how to use these systems and how to
learn from them there's lots of
resources on the web that you can use
the first one is the serviceworker
cookbook by Mozilla and that one is a
list of different service workers and
what they do by recipe so say like hey I
want to store my images offline here's a
recipe hour to do that I want to have a
lot of static content and a few net a
few dynamic things here's a
serviceworker that deals with that and
so on and so forth this isn't github
it's open-source if you wanna if you
want to commit to it I'm taking over
some of the maintenance of it right now
so there's a lot of good stuff in there
google has an API called work box which
is a JavaScript library that is on top
of serviceworker it makes it a bit
easier to use so as for a carotid and
understanding the API itself and reading
through a w3c documentation you can just
use work box and say like cache Network
first these 15 images and so on and so
forth that's been used by a lot of
companies out there when we did our
research and we looked at service
workers in the wild a lot of people are
using work box because it's
well-maintained and it's a simpler way
to use the API but if you really want to
know about serviceworker reading this
pack is probably a good idea as well I'm
working on PW a builder this one is a
website where you can go and you give it
a URL of your app and then it creates
the web manifest automatically for you
by scribe by going through the
information on in your HTML already and
then you can edit it and save it we also
pull your favicon and generate lots of
icons in different sizes and formats for
your application that you can download
as a zip file then it creates the
serviceworker
for offline functionality and push
notifications over
have a few recipes in there just like I
want this one this on this then creates
the serviceworker file then you upload
the serviceworker file and the end the
app manifest file to your application
server and then you can create binary
apps for older Android iOS and Windows
Store applications that way so you don't
need to actually build those you
probably I don't know if you really want
to have and get iOS to the nth degree
you will what you will write something
but this is a really good way to keep
your things in check maintain it in one
space and start building things with it
it also has a lot of documentation on it
and in-depth explanation what the
validator and generator for the web
manifests the service workers are so you
can upload your service workers there as
well and your manifests and we tell you
when there's problems in there when
there's accessibility issues with your
colors when there's like naming issues
with your names and so on and so forth
Google has a tool called lighthouse
which is an extension to the Google
developer tools
so in those developer tools you can it's
an add-on to it and you can look at your
application inside the inside chrome and
then it gives you audits for it it says
like it's a hundred progressive web app
88 performance 100 accessibility 85 best
practices and explains all the things
that were audited how they passed and
what things you can do better I love
this but I find it also dangerous
because people start playing to those
numbers rather than seeing if the
functionality really made sense for
their end-users so not everything needs
a notification but people who are
notification in now because otherwise
they don't get 100% so be sure to not
chase those numbers but actually make
sure what makes sense to your end-users
and if you use notifications please
please please use them responsibly
we don't want notifications to be the
next pop-ups we don't want those things
that just annoy the end user they should
give the end user a value and something
useful to do if a notification doesn't
have a button that needs to trigger
something it's probably not unnecessary
notification tell the end-users
something changed in the app why don't
you come back it's just depressing and
it's just desperate and many websites do
that right now you go to a website and
the first thing is like do you want to
subscribe to notifications for this
website buy me dinner first I don't even
know you who you are this
this is just push e push notifications
no that's where they're from what the
web can do today is a great resource
that shows you all the different API
stand that are basically as w3c
standards right now you got a Bluetooth
NFC and so on and so forth ambient light
sensor that's been around for ages it's
pretty cool actually and it actually
does a track on the browser that you're
currently using and gives you the
checkbox to say like hey that browser
already does that and this one brought
this browser you're currently using
don't do it and it clicks through
through the standards to actually read
up what they are about and what you
could use them for there's a PWA
directory which is not that maintained
because there's a lot of copy copy
things in there but it's fun to look at
other people doing their stuff and it's
the web you can look at the source code
of these things and understand how
they've done it there's PWA stats by
cloud for that shows you success stories
of pwace what people have done like flip
card and Forbes and know another time
Forbes okay settled refills hotels and
so forth so these are all like if you
need to convince your business people
there are great stories they're
sometimes depressing when you look at
them as well I remember there was a case
a year ago where I said lucky has a
sales company in Africa it's like
Africa's Amazon whatever that means and
they're like yeah and they used the PWA
and it collects 700 percent more
attention and like 50 times more users
and even on iOS cuz iOS not not support
serviceworker yet they had like they had
like an increase of 72% and I'm like
that's a really strange number what's
going on there
and then I talked to the product manager
of that one and it was not the full app
that became a PWA but only one that they
send out to 50 users and one of them was
an American tourist in Africa I had an
iPhone with them so that was the iPhone
usage there so never trust percentage is
not a good idea
pwace a great opportunity to clean up
our app act to make our apps better for
our end user and to not give them the
old apps not give them the mobile apps
not lock them into one device but give
them the functionality of apps without
forcing them to change their environment
the link is the distribution model and
this is the coolest thing about it
because that works everywhere you can
send a new you could find a news item
with a link in it an article a blog
post about a email a message a poster
and NFC beacon a movie product placement
or dog color all of these things can
have it can have links in them and once
you have it you just click on the link
you follow it the HTML loads the
JavaScript execute the serviceworker
starts running and the magic happens and
it becomes an application just by using
it and that way subsequent loads offer
more offline functionality and you can
ask for more permissions and instead of
asking people for every permission
before they even know who you are
so PWA to me is a try before you buy you
install the app by visiting it and
granting more permissions with more
visits and if you don't like it you
close it and it's gone and you don't
have to go through the uninstall process
of your mobile phone you don't have to
clean up your devices it's just there or
not there depending if you want to use
it or not use it you can allow users to
do what they came for and reach what
they want to reach don't demand them to
change their device or go to a store or
do something else
people already made a decision to follow
a link and trust you to get something
good so that way you can reach people
where they are and you don't ask them to
cater to you because you're not that
important I'm not an important nobody is
so let's simplify our products slim down
what we do the worst problems that we
have and rethink the approach and you
will reach new users that wait Google's
story about a pwace is all about like
Africa India Bangladesh all these places
that have a positive GDP that actually
have money that have growth but have
really shitty phones and really bad
connectivity so sending them a 50 mega a
pizz not gonna happen but sending them a
URL where they can actually load
something use something and store
something different story altogether
the PWA approach fixes the worst
problems of native apps and brings the
best of the web to the app space and
this is basically why I'm so excited
about it because I'm I'm a web guy I
love web I don't like apps too much but
I think we the function the tented
technology has moved on but we haven't
merged those two together we still think
these are two different spaces and
they're not why should I go through a
marketplace when I can have a link so
the whole PWA is all these things there
is the
nice thing to consider is still a great
idea but when it comes to messaging
inside Google Mozilla Safari and Samsung
and all the others there's always this
thing of fire
I hate acronyms I work for Microsoft we
have enough acronyms to tend to rest in
my life but what fire means is the first
thing think fast
random what is needed as fast as
possible if your app takes three seconds
to load you lost 70% of your users
because we're not on a mobile we're not
happy if something takes time on a
desktop we give it more time integrated
apps show up where they're supposed to
show up I don't need to want to go back
to the browser to use your application
once the application the serviceworker
and the manifest has worked I have an
icon on my machine I click on the icon
and when I go through the like alt tab I
find your app in there when I do the
search on the device I find did your app
in the app folder and not somewhere
random they're just integrated with
where you're supposed to find
applications they need to be responsive
so don't give the same interface on
mobile and on desktop it's very simple
nowadays to do different interfaces that
adapts to the availability and they need
to be engaging so use notifications and
background updates instead of just
asking people to update the thing all
the time themselves make them aware that
the that the app is working for them in
the background all the time and does
something useful and don't tell them
like oh next time oh you just loaded it
you have to reload it again remember
Windows updates not fun so this is for
example Twitter this is the native app
on Twitter this is Twitter light which
is the PWA you see the PWA loaded much
faster already it needs about a tenth of
the data that that the full app does but
it does all the functionality like it's
supposed to do it has the integration
with the camera it allows you to to set
and retweet and all the things you can
quote them you can upload your images I
used to eat with a light for a half a
year now and I don't miss anything and
if T if T if the experience is not the
same so [ __ ] what nobody nobody
compares them next to each other only
developers do that the amount of times
we have 12
open and we select a difference between
the two windows nobody cares
only we care or the people who don't
understand the web care end-users are
just happy if the thing is not broken on
their device in their environment if it
looks different on the desktop to a
mobile thank you you build something for
the web you didn't put a JPEG on the web
and hope that people like it that's all
I had so thanks very much
[Applause]